morning i've got the tractor
volunteering at the village vintage
vehicle show beats working for caroline
a pensions professional she retired
early after covid and lockdown made her
reassess her priorities that's your
exhibitor number and she's not looking
back
so many people were dying and
um or getting long covered and
i thought well this you know live while
you can you know who knows what's around
the corner you don't actually need a lot
of money but if you can do without
then you have the freedom and that is
the best medicine in the world
she's not the only one whose working
days are behind her whether through
choice or necessity she's part of a
cohort of missing workers that's fueling
a crisis in the labor market
since the pandemic hundreds of thousands
of people have dropped out of the
workplace they become economically
inactive in the jargon and that is
contributing to a genuine problem
companies simply cannot fill the
vacancies for the jobs the economy
requires to grow and recover
there are 1.29 million vacancies in the
jobs market that's half a million more
than before the pandemic
and more than the 1.28 million
unemployed job seekers but during the
same period half a million more people
became economically inactive through
sickness retirement or for other reasons
and 378 000 of them remain outside the
jobs market
it sort of ripped
every part of energy out of me
and from that point i never got better
nicola didn't choose to leave work an
nhs music therapist she was fit and
active before long covered cut her down
last year thinking nothing of hundred
mile bike rides
at 26 she's been unable to work for more
than six months
it is incredibly frustrating and
very difficult to watch your friends
sort of get on with their lives and
and know that you have to sort of just
be really patient with where you're at i
would love to go back to work i miss my
patients i miss my colleagues
i miss doing what gives me joy
if nicola needs to recover before she
can go back to work
the economy needs her and thousands like
her too before it can do the same
paul kelso sky news